This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6Nate English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam. Are you a saver or a spender, Sam?
Well, I'm trying to limit my spending right now because I'm saving up for a deposit to buy a house.
Saving money is not always easy as we'll find out in today's programme, which is all about
thrift. Thrift is not a simple idea to define. It's to do with living a simple life free from
the need to constantly buy the latest products. Today's consumer culture encourages us to spend,
spend, spend, spend, but it hasn't always been that way. The Victorians, for example, told people
to save up for a rainy day, meaning to keep some money back in case of unforeseen emergencies.
But before we discover more about that, it's time for today's quiz question.
If you're trying to save money, you probably know how hard it can be.
So my question is, what percentage of people in the UK do you think have less than a thousand
pounds in savings? Is it A, 5%, B, 15% or C, 30%.
Well, if I'm anything to go by, I'd say C, 30%.
Okay, well, we'll find the correct answer out later.
I mentioned before that thrift is a difficult idea to define. So here's Alison Hume, a lecturer at
the University of Northampton, explaining more to BBC Radio 4's programme Thinking Allowed.
Well, there are two dictionary definitions of thrift. The older of the two comes from the word
thrive, etymologically, and describes thrift as the ability to live well and to flourish. So it's
that sense of human flourishing. The more recent definition is the one we're probably more familiar
with, which is about frugality. All of that said, it's been used historically, of course, by various
people in various moments, in various different places, in very different ways. And they've often had
a social or religious agenda. It seems the oldest definition of thrift has nothing to do with
saving money and is connected to the verbs thrive and flourish, meaning to grow or develop successfully.
It was only later with the Puritans, 16th century English Christians with a reputation for strict
discipline, that the meaning of thrift changed and became associated with frugality,
being careful not to spend too much money or eat too much food. The Puritans believe that being
frugal was a religious virtue and that people ought to save money in order to give to others in need.
Later on, the meaning of thrift changed again. During the Victorian era, it was connected to the
idea of managing your own money in order to be a responsible citizen. Throughout history, then,
there have been different versions of thrift. And this may be because different religions or
social groups had their own agenda, a specific aim or reason for a particular group to do something.
For example, the Victorian definition of thrift was based on a social agenda about being a respectable
member of society. Ideas about frugality and thrift changed again during the Second World War,
when the public was encouraged to avoid waste so that every material resource could go into the war
effort. And in the post-war period, it changed again as people's wealth and standard of living
increased. Here's Alison Hume again. It's the idea that once people had enough to meet their
kind of basic needs, there was this kind of moral slide into consumerism. It's not a view that I
subscribe to in a simplistic sense myself. I think there's a very fine line to tready. There's no
point denying that certainly in the developed world there's been a rise in consumer capitalism,
that's just a truism. But thrift hasn't declined. In modern times, people's motivation to save
up and be thrifty declined once they had enough to meet their basic needs. The basic necessities
needed to survive, like food, clothes and shelter and nothing extra. Alison mentions that once these
basic needs were satisfied, people moved away from thrift into consumerism. The desire to buy
luxury products, which were not absolutely necessary. According to some, this created a moral
slide, a decrease in the standards of behaving in good, fair and honest ways. The rise in consumer
capitalism we have seen around the world is an example of a truism, something that is so obviously
true. It's not worth repeating. What is worth repeating is the quiz question, though, Neil.
Yes, I asked you how many British people had savings of under a thousand pounds? And I said,
see, 30%. In fact, Sam, it's B, 15%. No, so I guess I'm not such a bad saver after all.
Okay, well, today we've been talking about the changing meanings of thrift,
an idea connected to frugality. Being careful not to spend too much money.
The original meaning of thrift was too flourish, grow or develop successfully,
but that definition changed as different religious groups, like the Puritans, promoted their own
agenda. Aim or reason for a particular group to do something. In recent times, people's ability to
meet their basic needs, the necessities for survival, like food and shelter, have reduced the
importance of thrift, which some believe has created a moral slide, a reduction in standards of
moral behaviour. And the associated rise of consumer capitalism is an example of a truism,
something that is obviously true and generally accepted by all. That's all for now. Join us again
next time for more topical discussion and vocabulary by for now. Bye-bye.